so I pulled the Tweet up uh Nancy mace
Hillary Clinton used a hammer to destroy
evidence she did but you can argue the
semantics of it wasn't her personally
but she used bleach bit which is an open
source software to purge a hard drive
make it uh unrecoverable and then her
staff used hammers to destroy the phone
devices he responds you know that didn't
happen right are you okay you seem to
have been hallucinating a lot lately of
course he's fact checked then by CNN
Business Insider and Snopes proving
Hillary Clinton did in fact have her
phones destroyed by a hammer this is a
crazy thing I don't know if they're
lying or that they're just
is the problem
stupid people on the internet
are are tribal and will attract
followers and continue to say stupid
things
and then we're just arguing with brick
walls I used to give them the benefit of
the doubt I don't give them the benefit
of the doubt anymore very rarely do I
give them the benefit of the doubt that
I think that he just didn't know that I
think that a lot of them are just acting
in bad faith like like because because
that's because semantics do matter right
he says it didn't happen
like he said it says everything you're
saying is false it's wrong not that your
words are somehow incorrect or Hillary
didn't do it personally he's saying
everything you're saying is a lie which
is really important when she said
Hillary Clinton did it and that's not
true her staffer did it and that that's
stupid that's incorrect it's it's if if
you were going to if I claimed
definitively as a statement of fact
Hillary Clinton used a hammer to destroy
evidence in a private email server as a
hard statement of fact that that that's
action-proof like a judgment proof that
is a fact statement that is true and
provably true
now if I were to say Hillary Clinton
grabbed a hammer in her bare hands and
in a blinding rage shattered those
phones that would not be true
Hillary Clinton did use a hammer to
destroy the devices she had her staff
first take a hammer and use the hammer
to do it so it's a question of
when it comes to uh statements of fact
whether it's defamation or not what
Nancy May said is a true statement you
might you might argue well you should
clarify Hillary Clinton had staff
members destroy phones with a hammer and
that's probably a better way to phrase
it I don't think she was thinking I
don't think Nancy mace was like how do I
articulate this perfectly I think she
was like Hillary Clinton used the hammer
to do this because she did just if it
does imply that Hillary personally did
it I think clarification is fine Keith
Oberman is either lying or just
this is the problem
Keith olberman clearly is either lying
which I think we all would agree may be
the case or he's really really dumb and
arrogant now it's possible he is both
dumb arrogant and lying the point of
semantic arguments is to obfuscate the
point of the discussion it's to get you
distracted and now you're no longer
talking about what the actual
consequences of the emails are the point
of it is to talk about oh now we're
talking about that's very it's not
waving it it's no longer so now you're
no longer talking about why should I say
the emails why she destroyed any of this
why she deleted all these things now
you're talking about the semantics of
the argument then you don't even get to
the actual debate about what happened
and that's basically social media in a
nutshell and they would do anything in
order to say it's mostly false or
partially false so if you said she
destroyed her blackberries and one of
the seven devices was a Nokia they would
be like um
that's the real question and they use
the red and green color too this is what
Snopes does
I you will come out and say Hillary
Clinton had her phone smashed with a
hammer Snopes won't take that statement
because that statement is is yes or no
they will make up their own question did
Hillary Clinton smash her phone with a
hammer who we're not saying that we're
saying that her she had it done they've
reframed the question so they can then
say mixture
well Hillary Clinton did not personally
destroy what I love what they do is
the headline question the game is one
they do there's also the uh false
qualifier a statement they'll do
um Donald Trump will do a backflip off
the balcony of the White House and land
in a superhero pose and they'll say did
Donald Trump actually do a backflip off
the back into the White House into a
superhero pose comma on Sunday false in
big letters they'll then write 500 words
about the story and the claims at the
bottom and say well it is true he did
the backflip it was on Saturday not
Sunday live ice structure exactly making
sure that they read you got to click the
CNN link that nobody ever reads to the
end of the article the CNN ones the
famous one where they're like no no pull
that up pull that up
this is from uh this from a while ago
let's play it is it going to play they
might have an ad it might be in their oh
no no why because the FBI had an
exhaustive year-long investigation they
talked to probably dozens and dozens and
dozens of people hours hours and hours
at testimony and the decision not to
recommend uh prosecutions for who's
absolutely unanimous was it careless yes
was it a mistake yes as Hillary Clinton
said I should not have done this and if
I ever had to do it again I'd make a
difference it was a criminal no it was
not criminal so I guess that's the
Benchmark now to become president
there's not to be a criminal to become
let's go through the factors unlike 17
17 500 emails that she lied about
turning over the server wipe within
weeks of there being a report the she
had a private server it was wiped she
thought that c which stands for
classified stood for cookie or something
which stands for classified she thought
that dry strikes are not classified she
said that the reason she used this
private servers for convenience and she
only had one device she used 13 black
bears let me finish and five iPads at
least she doesn't just stick to either
Blackberry iPad this is somebody who is
absolutely disqualified from becoming
president they destroyed blackberries
with hammers in the state department
that's not what won the president
cameras fact check that for me please on
the Fly uh yes they did
[Laughter]
in some way were used with with her
private email server and they did in
some cases just destroy them with
hammers when they were done which
doesn't do anything to stop the the to
get rid of the data on it you can easily
you can like
I'll be very careful with my words
even after these things are burned and
fires you can still recover data from
them and it's it's the smash it with
hammer absolutely idiotic so the
question then is why is aldermen
asserting something that is not true is
it because he's stupid and arrogant or
is he intentionally trying to lie I I
believe that the left has a Munchausen
by proxy relationship with their
audience and that they intentionally lie
because they know that their occult that
will only believe what comes out of the
glowing box and they want that cult to
be manipulatable they need that cult to
be actionable and there's they need them
to be the NPC meme right where you just
take you take the chip out of the back
of the head and you replace it with
black lives matter or the transgender
flag or whatever so you need to be
programmable they want programmable
people George Orwell talks about this uh
in 1984 you need these people to be
programmable the the value of a loyal
servant is what lie will you swallow the
value of the loyal servitude of the left
the Borg is will you say that two plus
two equal equals five that's right there
are five lights
you mentioned the Borg so I had to make
it to start your preference yeah my game
is the famous uh story is when Captain
Picard's being tortured there are four
lights and he's told to say there are
five and he refuses so they keep
torturing him until but he never does it
I was yesterday I was pretty down
thinking like oh actually maybe evil
triumphs over good usually and they just
tell everyone that they were the good
guys like what is this whole I felt so
down and so like hopeless and then I was
like oh how easy it would be to just say
yo go Ukraine I'm all in I'm gonna get
my Central Bank digital currency just
let me live in peace I don't want to
think about it how easy yeah yes the
Borg the Borg life is easy you sit back
you ever seen Wally you just sit back if
you're a slob you're in your floating
chair have you seen that movie the
school for good and evil so I'm I'm
unable to work so of course I'm just
watching whatever's available and I
watched this movie The and it's
basically it's a it's like a kid teenage
movie or whatever where I don't know
what the point the point of the movie
was pretty dumb but the idea is that in
the fairy tale world there's a school
that has an evil side and a good side
and they train all the prince charmings
and they train all the wicked witches
and uh spoiler alert I'm gonna ruin the
story for all of you
um as to to go on to but you've been
warned spoiler uh the actual outcome of
the story is the good side was corrupted
hundreds of years ago and they had
become Vain and vapid and snooty and
narcissistic and they were gloating
about how good they were but they were
actually fairly corrupted and evil and
so you know that was to your point like
I just watched this movie and that was
the idea they they actually conveyed
that what we think of as good has been
corrupted a long time ago and now it's
just vanity it's like the Biden
Administration you see this all the time
signaling they just wrap themselves in
the American flag they wrap themselves
in democracy Merrick Garland said it
today he was called on his
today on going to a party last night at
the White House with the guy he's
supposed to be investigating two guys
Jim Biden and Hunter Biden he's supposed
to be investigating both of them and
Merrick Garland is at a party with them
so you said earlier so Merrick Garland
said today sorry to interrupt you but I
just gotta finish his comment today was
if you attack the Department of Justice
you're attacking our democracy that's
what he said if you question the
Department of Justice you're attacking
our democracy it's always ours democracy
evil and you were saying smart people
would impeach mayor Garland and let Joe
Biden run the reason that the reporters
are going haywire now and just turning
on Biden is because they feel ashamed
about how they were misled about the
submersible story was that assumption
that's what I that's what I think I
think you embarrass them and make them
look bad personally they're Petty and
they get mad at that and as for the
Keith Olbermann thing remember he's an
anchor actor he doesn't do what you do
where you do your research and then you
somebody else puts the things in the
prompter so he might not be I don't
think he's technically stupid but he
might actually not be lying look I I
think I genuinely think that a large
component of the culture War divide is
intelligence
and we were having this joke about doing
a culture War episode where we uh who I
think Sheamus made the joke he said
there's this new podcast where they get
a bunch of you know young girls who have
never was that was that James said that
young girls who have never been
challenged on anything and then make
them look stupid or whatever and then we
were all joking about how we should have
like a 56 year old PhD conservative Guy
debate like three 18 year old does the
whatever podcast already do that yeah
they did recently actually with like a
55 year old PhD he was like a doctor and
he was talking to girls had some
credential but the the joke was that the
girls would actually win because the guy
would be like when you read this study
here we can see this from you know
sordinson at all they talk about and
they're like oh you are so dumb and then
we're gonna start they're being like
don't you think he's stupid say it again
said you're dumb and he's gonna be like
can you let me finish my point and
they're gonna laugh then they're gonna
start calling him names and then he's
gonna be like do you agree that there is
a larger percentage of X when it comes
to Y and they're like you mean like at a
pizza shop he's like no I'm talking
about the economics in this country and
I mean here you want to buy pizza and
he's going to be like I can't do this
it's impossible these people and they'll
be like that's not hot I'm gonna go have
babies yeah this is the culture War when
we sit down with someone and this is why
you don't see liberals come on shows
like this they rarely want to there's a
small handful that do and they often
grift and then I'm like this is the
problem we run into when we do things
like this when you and I I I it's kind
of like rehashing the show we did this
morning I know that but at the same time
when I see Keith olberman tweeting this
it just it it brings this up to me that
you can't have a conversation with
someone who is you can't argue policy
with someone who can't comprehend policy
and that is the culture War today if you
say something like you know I I think
that we need to I'll give you an example
we were talking about uh the issue of
trans kids and I said we have a study
that shows desistance is 68 to 95 61 to
95 percent uh with no intervention that
would indicate that no intervention is
the safest course of action for children
and Emma did not understand that and
said but the doctors say it's good so we
should do it and if if my point is the
study we have suggests X and the
response is but the government but I
shouldn't say government but the the
authority says it's good we're not you
can't you can't convince someone who
doesn't understand the math of the
science or the argument it just it's a
brick wall I think that's a debate
appeal to Authority it's literally yeah
I said that over and over and over again
appeal to Authority and that's why the
school system's so good at it right
because they're trained to appeal to
Authority right from the very beginning
so they're just going to defer to
whatever the person in charge says even
if there's data that proves that person
in charge to be incorrect so a really
good example of the challenges we're
facing in the culture war from this
morning for those that listen to this
show you all know that we've actually
had this debate quite a bit over what it
means to to uh support parental rights
Rhonda Santos passes this bill Fuller
legislature or the parental rights and
education and then we have the
conversation of what what does it mean
to be in favor of parents rights what if
the parents want the right to have a
doctor prescribe a sex change to their
child well every conservative media says
no you don't have that right and the
government should stop you okay so it's
not parental rights then on the left I I
actually asked Emma what about the
government mandating children get
vaccine she goes well yes I believe in
public health and I'm like okay so
you're not in favor of parental rights
you can you the saying you're you're for
against parental rights is a completely
meaningless statement because everyone's
moral line is going to be completely
different we talk about that quite a bit
she could not grasp that concept and
it's very difficult to have a real
conversation with someone who doesn't
understand the or none of that but can't
actually comprehend basic moral
philosophy so it's if we're if we're
sitting in a room and we're saying let
us break down why we have the policy
should we enact a different policy and
how can we make the lives better for
everybody and they say
duh
I don't understand what you're saying we
can't carry around that conversation she
called hypotheticals right wing right
right she was like I'm not going to
engage in your right-wing tactic of
hypotheticals it's amazing it was wild
to hear that so but this is exactly the
point you get a bunch of people when I
was mentioning the conservative PhD guy
and a bunch of young girls who are just
giggling and laughing and saying you're
dumb there's no conversation to be had
now here's the real challenge those
three giggling dumb vapid teenage girls
have three votes to that conservative
phd's one vote and this is what we're
dealing with in the culture war and I
bring this up because I'm seeing like
the Keith Urban thing
when it comes to issues of barisma when
it comes to issue of issues of Hillary
Clinton doing these things these are not
left or right-wing things these are
things that are discernably true that we
have questions about I can sit here and
be like Barack Obama killed Abdullahi in
a drone strike in a civilian restaurant
in Yemen and he should be he should be
criminally charged and prosecuted and if
found guilty be be held accountable for
murder of an American citizen Donald
Trump ordered a Commando rating Yemen
which reportedly according to the family
resulted in the death of an
eight-year-old girl abdullahi's sister
that should be investigated if it is
brought to an investigation Trump should
be charged same as Obama however I think
that story might be a bit less credible
than the Obama one which we know for a
fact did happen they've admitted to I
still think both warrant the same legal
jurisprudence I can say those things
but for some reason when you have a
conversation with someone like Keith
Olbermann or magnesium liberals they
will just be like
the barisma video never happened and I'm
like you you know you're making that up
because we have the video to play it did
happen and they're saying he was never
being investigated but we know for a
fact and there's a sworn affidavit from
shoken there were a dozen investigations
into into my closet instead of actually
engaging with you they'll either be
unable to actually comprehend the the
moral philosophy or the math and science
behind what you're arguing and then
they'll just lie thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time